The one I think is best is option A. One thing to think about when you look at
the module[UNKNOWN] things and try to decide which is best. If it's a good
module, we should be able to give it a name. It should be conceptually
corresponding to something we're thinking about, and if you look at the modules
here, the way A is defined, all of the things in A are thing that you can do
before a query comes in. These are things that you're doing based on just
building the corpus of the web. All of the things in the second module here are
thing that you can do only after a query comes in. And it makes a lot of sense
to divide those two phases. In version B, I've grouped lookup in the first
module, and lookup is used by both lucky search and ordered search. It's not
used by any of the functions that build the corpus. So it doesn't really make a
lot of sense to have it here. If we have it here, the interface between these
two modules is going to be much more complex than it would be if we put lookup
in the second module. So that's why I prefer option A to either of the other
two. Option C doesn't really make much sense to have lookup be all its own
module. There are certainly other options, and I would encourage you to discuss
them in the forum, if you have another suggestion of how to modularize this.